Xin Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học
lũ Bảo Nam lúc video ngày hôm nay Đỗ Bảo
Nam blog spot cách xóa cột Xóa dòng
trong Word
A và trong video này Đỗ Bảo Nam blog
đang dùng word 2021 các phiên bản Quốc
có hơn như 2019 2016 2013 vân vân việc
Xóa dòng hoặc xóa cột bạn thấy hoàn toàn
tương tự
do sửa đây đâu vào Nam vào lúc đã chuẩn
bị sẵn một cái bảng như thế này bây giờ
mình sẽ chia sẻ hai cách để bạn khỏe Xóa
dòng hoặc cột
cách duy nhất bạn hao tác chiến thành
Red Bull
cách này bạn thực hiện 2 bước như sau
Bước 1 bạn chọn vị trí Cần xóa cột hoặc
Xóa dòng
với râu bây giờ mình sẽ xóa cái cối
email này thì đầu tiên bạn hãy cưới
chuột vào cái cô này
trong trường hợp bạn muốn xóa nhiều cột
thì bạn có thể bôi Đem các cột cần xóa
và đây và chỉ cần bôi đen một phần của
cột mà không cần phải ở cột
cho ví dụ bây giờ mình vẫn quay trở về
để xóa một cõi mail
Ô thế mình cứ chọn vào cái cột email
Vì sao đó Bước thứ hai bạn vào đây Down
ở trên menu à
em
và bạn tìm đến chrysalid mà bạn nhấp vào
đây
Chọn Danny klum để xóa cột
ở trong trường hợp bạn muốn xóa dòng thì
bạn nhấp vào Dennis Chrome Và nếu muốn
xóa bảng thì bạn nhấp vào đây hết people
ở đây mình sẽ chọn nichols để xóa cồn
Ừ
Hình như vậy bạn thấy mình đã vừa sáng
Một Cột
a tiếp theo mình sẽ sang Cách thứ 2 đó
là sử dụng thì phải
hứa trâu bây giờ mình sẽ xóa ba cái dòng
trắng ở cuối cùng là đi
Ờ thì đầu tiên bạn hãy Bôi đen các dòng
tấn xóa
ở trong trường hợp bạn chỉ sáng một dòng
thì bạn không cần phải modem Mà bạn chỉ
cần risus ID vào dòng toàn Xóa Tuy nhiên
ở đây mình xóa 3 dòng do vậy mình cần
phải Model các dòng thần xóa các bạn có
thể bôi D1 tuần của dòng cũng được hoặc
Model toàn bộ nội dung của dòng
ạ sau đó bạn click chuột phải
và chọn đen Excel II
sau khi hộp thoại để biết xe vẫn ra bạn
tích chuột và cái dòng thứ ba đó là đen
hết không có nghĩa là Xóa dòng con nếu
bạn muốn xóa cột thì bạn hãy click và
Dennis Gold ở đây mình sẽ chọn cái đến
đít không
phải là sau đó bạn Click vào ok
như vậy Mình vừa xóa nhanh ba dòng ở
trong cái bạn mà bạn nhìn thấy trên màn
hình
và video của mình sẽ kết thúc tại đây
nếu bạn có những câu hỏi cần hỗ trợ bạn
hãy comment trực tiếp bằng phía dưới này
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp theo
Ừ
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích Bạn hãy nhấp chuột vào nay và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ Đỗ bà Nam với Đông
thai Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam
lúc bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video hữu ích từ đỗ và nam và lúc
Xin cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn phải tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa đỗ vào Nam với
và truy cập website đô Bảo Nam blach.com
hoặc kênh YouTube để bàn ăn blog để xem
thêm các video hữu ích như thủ thuật máy
tính tay calypso Cruiser
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ bàn ăn bước chúng con
để cập nhật những bài viết thôi mới nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
Ngày mai bạn ở các video tiếp theo